flurry of yoga Nikolayevich says Dell
Institute Padilla had clearly elements
to eternal sit in this Vanya at very me
enter Europe I mean Nick Brady and I was
so excited that element 114 has finally
got its official name that we felt that
I should try and say a few words in
Russian because my father was born in
Russia we've already made two videos
about the discovery of this element
first of all how the discovery was
confirmed and people really established
that 114 had been made and then the
first time that the name was mentioned
at the end of the 2011 International
Year of chemistry so what's new and
what's new is that on the 30th of May
this year 2012 the elements name was
officially adopted and therefore we can
make a new video to go in our periodic
table of videos so this is the official
video of the element depending whether
you say it with a Russian accent or not
is called fluoro Veeam or flew rhodium
element 114 there is no official
periodic table in the same way that
there's a standard kilogram but when a
name is suggested such as the main-floor
ovum was suggested in december last year
then people are allowed a few months to
point out if there are any problems in
the case of element 112 copernicium the
symbol was changed from CP to C n
during this discussion period in the
case of Floridian nothing has changed
and the element symbol is f L big f
little L there in some fonts it looks
like f 1 which is possibly a problem now
like the other super-heavy elements
these elements are synthesized
by taking the nucleus of a heavy element
or an atom of a heavy element and
banging into it an element that is
lighter and so in this case they take
plutonium which is element 94 and to
make 114 you need 20 so you take a
nucleus of calcium which has atomic
number 20 you accelerate calcium very
rapidly and eventually after bombarding
plutonium with millions and hundreds of
millions of atoms one of them will fuse
together you can see it's quite hard you
now have an element with the nucleus of
atomic number 114 that's with a hundred
and fourteen protons that flies off to
be analyzed these experiments were done
in the Russian Research Center Dubois
north of Moscow which was founded by
academician flurry of the earlier
elements like element 105 there was huge
nationalistic competition between Newton
s labs and Russian labs and arguing who
discovered it first these elements 114
and 116 which were named at the same
time are a beautiful example of
international collaboration this element
like the ones around it has only been
seen in the number really quite small
number of atoms so nobody has made any
compound from it though if you look at
the periodic table you will see it's in
the same group as lead this cap here was
made before the name was announced so it
says has the old symbol uuq and you
would expect the chemistry of floor viim
to be rather like that of lead only
rather more so so you might expect it to
be a very dense and rather soft metal
highly radioactive
you couldn't use it as weights for your
fishing like people use led but it would
probably be poisonous even if it were
not radioactive and it's chemistry might
be quite similar too late though as you
go down the periodic table you can get
quite some surprises now the real
question that you might all be asking is
if you can only make a few atoms of this
element why on earth does it need a
symbol nobody is going to be writing
textbooks about the chemistry of Fleur
ovm with fluoro VM oxide of the rhodium
sulfate so why do you need this symbol
and the answer is that the symbol
probably isn't used useful in chemistry
but it's very useful in physics because
as you go to heavier elements say
element 116 118 they will decay via some
of these other elements like 114 and so
if you want to make charts like this one
that I've got on my tie with the
different elements and how they decay
away as they give out radioactive
particles gamma rays you need the
symbols and if you don't have the symbol
then it's quite difficult to construct
these so the simple does have a use even
though it's not particularly useful for
day-to-day chemistry I've been to Russia
quite frequently lots and lots of times
to Moscow but not yet to do now though
it's one of the places that Brady and I
really want to go
I have heard a flurry off of course and
his institute but I think that it is
rather sad that although he was alive at
the time that these elements were
discovered the experiments were done
that he died before the name of was
officially announced and so this is why
at the beginning of the video I said
that the name of this element is really
his memorial and I think it's a very
positive memorial because it symbolizes
how science has brought countries of the
world together in a way although I
didn't know him that I'm sure in his
heart he really wanted can I ask you a
question would you rather have an
element named after you or win a Nobel
Prize
well I think that's that's a very
interesting question
you